a new tape brakes from Michael Cohen
president Trump slams the media and
Elizabeth Warren makes her pitch I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
a lot of breaking news today but let's
begin with this I have some exciting
news to announce I know you've all been
waiting with bated breath for this
particularly my college fans right now
we are about to announce where exactly I
shall be going with the FK young
America's Foundation last month we
announced the finalists from I fall
campus tour those are the schools that
might just might be so lucky as to risk
the ire of trigger left to students when
the hurricane that is me comes to campus
well today I'm excited to announce the
six colleges that make the cut so here
we go drumroll please USC okay so we
begin with University of Southern
California on October 4th and then we
move on to university at buffalo at octa
on October 8th North Central College on
October 10th University of
wisconsin-milwaukee on November 12th
Ohio State University on November 13th
and University of Pittsburgh on November
14th so if you are looking for tickets
at any of those lucky schools then make
sure you go over to ya org slash Shapiro
tour YF dot org slash Shapiro tour and
get this we now have a shirt at or short
it's an official Ben Shapiro Yap tour
shirt it will be available on Amazon in
our new merch store that's right the
Shapiro store is finally open at long
last you survived to see it you can wear
the shirt when you come to see me speak
at your school or you can frame it and
treasure it hang it on the walls you
watch the livestream gaze at it every
evening knowing that you've made your
life better and they've made the world a
better place if you'd like me to visit
your campus in 2019
then definitely check out ya org slash
Shapiro tour and that's where you can
learn how to apply to bring me to your
school I have to say these t-shirts are
pretty cool although it would be kind of
douchey for me to wear a t-shirt with my
own face on it but why would that stop
me I mean come on we've met haven't we
okay before we go any further I also
wanna mention your Second Amendment
right so you've heard all these stories
in the news where a kid gets hold of a
firearm and then something terrible
happens well you don't want that to
happen to you obviously but you also
want to make sure that you're exercising
your first your Second Amendment rights
which is why you need to go talk with my
friends at the u.s. ECA they want to
give your entire family 100% free guide
an audiobook for complete firearms
conference is a person with two kids
under the age 5 I want to make sure that
I'm doing firearm safety correctly you
should to go to defend my family now
calm right now for your brand-new kids
and guns guide that's defend my family
now calm you'll learn the most dangerous
mistake
that put kids at risk proven strategies
for teaching gun safety to kids the
right way eight life-saving tips to
responsibly own and store a gun and a
whole lot more it has never been easier
to educate every single member of your
family the guide is life-saving and
you'll get it 100% free when you go over
to defend my family now calm it's only
available for a few days and don't miss
it go over to defend my family now DICOM
get that free life-saving guide and the
peace of mind that you deserve let's
defend my family now.com again defend my
family now.com you SDC is a wonderful
organization helping you exercise your
second Amendment rights properly go
check it out defend my family now calm
alright so last night late in the
evening Chris Cuomo the slightly lesser
block of wood known as the Cuomo
brothers Chris Cuomo on CNN brought out
his big reveal what was his big reveal
his big reveal is that Michael Cohen the
president's former lawyer his personal
attorney had revealed a tape woo a tape
now we know tape is always bad except if
the tape doesn't tend to show a whole
hell of a lot so here's what happened
Michael Cohen apparently was talking
with the President of the United States
before he was the President of the
United States this is during the 2016
campaign
and he decided to basically wear a wire
into his conversations with Trump or at
least to carry a tape recorder in his
pocket now this is not illegal and a lot
of people saying today isn't that
illegal like the President of the United
States was tweeting out that he thought
that maybe this was illegal
this is his tweet this is 19 so the
president tweeted out what kind of a
lawyer would tape a client so sad is
this a first never heard of it before
why was the tape so abruptly terminated
cut well I was presumably saying
positive things I hear there are other
clients and many reporters that are
taped can this be so too bad okay well
it's not illegal for Cohen to tape
trumpet is weird it's very weird to tape
a conversation with your client because
the only point of taping a conversation
with your client presumably would be
either blackmail or the possibility of
violating attorney-client privilege or
maybe you want to show your client later
that he said something that he said he
didn't say but like I'm a lawyer I've
never taped a conversation with a client
because that'd be extraordinarily weird
it is indeed a weird thing to do it is
not illegal because the state of New
York oddly enough is one-party consent
state there are different laws in
different states around the country as
far as whether you can tape people so
California where I live is a two-party
consent state you cannot tape a
conversation with anyone unless it's for
news purpose
you're not allowed to tape a
conversation with anybody without that
person's consent which is why you
generally have to get release forms or
you least have to ask on the tape
whether it's okay to tape that's not the
case in New York and New York so long as
one of the members of the conversation
is okay with the taping in this case
Michael Kohn the taping is in fact legal
so they're taping and what exactly are
they talking about well apparently
they're having a conversation about how
to pay off Karen McDougal Karen McDougal
is another one of the bevy of porn stars
that President Trump stooped during his
during his great adventures in the in
the Vietnam that is the STD ridden world
of pornography
so Karen McDougal is former Playboy
Playmate and the president has basically
had sex with I think 10 out of every 12
Playboy Playmates at last count he did
yeah
well that let's not be shy about this
the president is not exactly a sexual
miser he's been rather profligate with
his services and with the services of
others for several decades and none of
this is a shock because as I say all of
this is priced in but we knew all of
this about Trump for years this guy who
used to openly brag about stopping other
people's wives like all of this is
priced in whether you like it whether
you don't
nothing's gonna change people who like
Trump like Trump they don't care about
this people who don't like Trump don't
like Trump they're gonna pretend they
care about this if they're on the left
while they don't care about Bill Clinton
and there are a few people on the right
who aren't fond of Trump's character and
also don't like that this is the stuff
that he does that's a shrinking group of
people in any case the president is
speaking with Michael Kohn and Cowan is
saying we need to pay off Karen McDougal
and here is what it sounds like a
company for the transfer of all of that
info regarding our friend David you know
so that I'm gonna do that right away and
I spoke to Alan about it when it comes
time for the financing which will be
okay so he then said the part of that
conversation that actually matters is
the very end so what's happening here is
that there is a guy who owns the
National Enquirer and his name is David
pecker he is not a joke that's his
actual name and he and president Trump
are apparently very close friends and
the way that this this this shtick would
work is that David pecker would go and
buy the life rights for all of these
women who had stripped Trump and then
Trump would set up a shell corporation
then pay David pecker to actually convey
those rights to Donald Trump's and these
stories would never hit the press and
apparently there's a fairly regular
thing according to various news reports
well as the election approached Michael
Cohen comes to trump and he says David
pecker has just bought the rights to
Karen McDougal story about stopping you
and he says we need to basically figure
out a way to pay David pecker for those
rights we need to give him some cash and
then he'll give us the the information
and then the information will never go
anywhere and so we'll set up a shell
corporation that nobody really knows
about and the key part of that is the
very end where Trump says something
about cash and then Cohn says back to
him no no no no okay
and what's unclear exactly is what Trump
is saying so it's Trump saying that we
need to pay off David pecker in cash or
is he saying we need to sign him a check
instead the reason this makes a
difference is because none of this is
particularly relevant there's nothing
illegal about me paying off somebody to
keep silent signing a settlement
agreement buying their life rights if
God forbid I were to have an affair or
something and pay somebody off that is
actually not illegal because not
blackmail it's just me paying somebody
off it's a legal agreement for somebody
to shut up so Trump has done this
apparently a lot there's nothing illegal
about that so he's not in any legal
trouble for that as Alan Dershowitz has
pointed out where there could
theoretically be legal trouble is we are
approaching the 2016 election and Trump
wants to keep Karen McDougal silent and
so this act is essentially a campaign
expenditure the reason he's paying off
Karen McDougal is because he wants her
to keep quiet in the run-up to the
election same sort of accusations were
made about Stormy's annuals that the
reason the president actually paid off
stormy Daniels is because he thought
that if those stories broke right before
the election he wouldn't win the
presidency and he wanted to keep those
people quiet so he paid them a bunch of
money and then more importantly he
didn't actually report that to the FEC
so if it's a campaign expenditure and he
didn't report it to the Federal
Elections Commissioner then that could
be a violation of campaign finance law
now he's it really a violation of
campaign finance law he very difficult
to say yes considering the John Edwards
did the same thing back in 2008 you
remember John Edwards that guy right
Breck hare girl you remember that guy he
in 2008 was one of the frontrunners for
the Democratic presidential nomination
but he'd been knocking on one of the
photographer's on his campaign he
actually knocked her up he actually got
her pregnant and then he had a bunch of
his campaign supporters paying her like
a million dollars to shut up and this
came to light and they tried to
prosecute him for campaign finance
violations and
prosecution fell through there's a hung
jury and then they never retried him so
it's difficult to say that Trump did
anything wildly different than anything
that John Edwards did back in 2008 that
said the media think they finally have
president Trump they think this will be
the porn star that finally takes down
the president it's like Lucy with the
football basically there's a story that
comes out with Trump stopping a porn
star and then paying her off and the
media says ah now we have him now we
have him and Trump kind of nods slowly
like Jack Nicholson in that in that gift
he kind of just nods slowly and then the
Democrats approach the football Trump
pulls away the football and and the
Democrats and the media go flying
through the air now the reason that
Democrats are really excited is because
they think Michael Cohen has even worse
material on Trump that is unclear at
best we know that there is something
like 12 tapes between Trump and Cohen
supposedly or 12 tapes that Cohen has we
don't know what's on those tapes we know
eventually they will leak Cohen's lawyer
is suggesting that this tape itself is
evidence of illegal activity by the
President of the United States so this
is this is Lanny Davis
so Lanny Davis was last seen in 1998
defending President Clinton and now here
he is on the other side going after
President Trump basically history
repeats itself the first time is tragedy
the second time is farce this is the
farce
here's Lanny Davis Michael Cohen's
lawyer on what these tapes supposedly
show we know that Trump has lied even
during the campaign when this campaign
spokesman denied two months after this
tape that he knew anything about Karen
McDougal
ladies and gentlemen if you voted for
Donald Trump listen to the tape and ask
yourself is Donald Trump lying when he
said he didn't use the word cash and
accuses Michael Kohn of using the word
cash okay so there is that and is he is
really in a situation where President
Trump is lying about cash or checks it
doesn't matter honestly legally speaking
it doesn't matter if you paid cash
doesn't matter if you paid for a check
the only real question is whether he
reported it to the FEC or whether he
even had to if it turns out that Trump
regularly paid off women to keep silent
this probably is not an election
violation but Lanny Davis is gonna make
this as look as bad as humanly possible
why why is Michael Cohen doing this
because Michael Cohen thinks that he's
going to be prosecuted and if he flips
on the president that his prosecution
will basically be kicked to the to the
second priority position that it just
won't matter as much so Michael Cohen's
lawyer continues he says only drug
dealers and mobsters use cash the idea
here is to make Trump look as bad as
possible so that it looks like Cohn
actually has material gotta say Cohen is
is is pretty sleazy dude here now this
is not to excuse the president's sexual
profligacy it's not to excuse the fact
that Donald Trump has a really really
poor history with women it's not to
excuse any of those things but when I
see this situation the first thing that
occurs to me is Michael Cohen was happy
to ride on Trump's coattails for years
and take his money and play his
protection man and then the minute
things go wrong he's out there ratting
on him but it's not even ratting about
anything that's necessarily illegal he's
just ratting on him in order to avoid
culpability for other activities perhaps
but Lanny Davis says that this is
mobster type stuff what trumped in here
there's no way that mr. Giuliani who
knows from being US Attorney the only
people who use cash are drug dealers and
mobsters cash is not what you do okay so
again I think this is this is an
exaggerated case being made by a lot of
folks on the left they think they're
really gonna get Trump this time
apparently they do Zhu Rudy Giuliani has
been caught in a little bit of a pickle
this is the president's lawyer he's been
caught in a little bit of a pickle
because he suggested that Trump only
paid via check he never would have paid
via cash now it appears that he may have
paid via cash but again I don't think
that any of this gonna make a large
difference I'm gonna explain that in
just a second first let's talk about the
software that you are using for your
company
okay you're dealing with a real
head-scratcher and having your go-to
person
on call is a no-brainer and this is
particularly true when it comes to the
world of software which is really really
complex when it comes to picking the
right software for your business
software advice has done all the
research for you their team of advisers
can point you in the right direction so
you can start working more effectively
right now and it's absolutely free just
go to software advice calm /ban answer a
few short questions about your business
you will be connected with an advisor to
discuss the best software options for
your needs talking to an advisor it can
take ten minutes or less whether you're
a medical professional construction
manager HR pro software advice saves you
time and helps you make a more informed
decision we here at the daily wear
offices talk to the folks at software
advice because we use an awful lot of
technology and we need to know what is
the best technology to use so whether
you are any of those jobs you're going
to need software vice and if you're
entrepreneur or I work solo software
advice is a great way to get an expert
opinion even without the resources of a
big company so they're on call and it
can help you figure out your business
software in minutes for free go check
them out software advice.com slash pens
get started that software advice.com
slash been software advice.com slash pen
go and check it out
okay so rudy giuliani comes out in
president Trump's defense he says listen
President Trump is not an idiot he
didn't do anything illegal here there's
no way the president is gonna be talking
about setting up a corporation and then
using catch unless you're a complete
idiot any chance president's not idiot
okay well you know I honestly think
that's sort of an irrelevant point in
the end is this going to take down Trump
no of course this isn't going to take
down Trump now what we do have to
discuss here is the way that the media
has treated this particular issue so
when it was President Clinton okay again
I don't mean to misdirect away from the
supposedly central issue which is how
President Trump acted with regard to
money when it was John Edwards when it
was President Clinton when it was Ted
Kennedy the media buried this stuff okay
the media were not interested in
covering this stuff when it comes to
Barack Obama's college transcripts we
still don't have those when it comes to
tapes that are being released by Michael
cone then the media is eager to run all
of those right this is the same media
who decry all the people who are running
all of the Hillary Clinton emails that
were being put out there by WikiLeaks
the same media is now saying well you
know if we decide to run these tapes
it's totally fine to run these tapes in
the end none of this is going to matter
the reason it's not going to matter is
because everybody already has an opinion
on President Trump everybody already
knows this is the sort of stuff that
President Trump does none of this is
particularly telling none of it is
particularly revealing and none of it is
particularly troubling if you already
like President Trump so all of this talk
about this is going to take down Trump
seems to be wildly exaggerated and it's
a level of enthusiasm that I think is is
rather uncalled for given the fact that
everybody already assumed all this stuff
was true it's so funny every time the
left thinks they catch President Trump
in a lie what they realize that most
Americans already thought he was fibbing
hey this is the part that I think the
media don't understand even people on
the right who say that they believe
President Trump at every turn they
understand when he's fibbing okay
everybody on the right who says yeah no
we believe Trump when he says he never
stopped stormy Daniels everyone
the right believes that he should up
storming Daniels and no one cares
because they already figured that that
was baked into the cake the same thing
is true of Karen McDougal they figured
Trump's gonna say what Trump's gonna say
to get himself off the hook but they're
very understanding about that because
they feel as though President Trump is
being unfairly targeted and to a certain
extent they're not wrong President Trump
is being unfairly targeted in the sense
that if the same stuff had happened with
regard to a Democrat it is highly
doubtful whether the media would be
treating this with anything like the
same sort of enthusiasm so all the talk
about why is it that Trump supporters
don't just understand why don't they get
on the bandwagon that he's a bad guy who
does bad things well the answer is
because they already priced that in and
what they decided is that they don't
trust you more than they don't trust
President Trump because they know where
Trump is lying but they don't know where
you are lying
Trump's lies are predictable from fibs
are predictable we know exactly what
he's gonna say about Karen McDougal when
it comes to the media we don't know when
they're going to say something
completely wildly untrue now here's a
great example of that so yesterday
President Trump was speaking at a
veteran's group and he started talking
about the fake news right one of his
favorite topics and he suggested that we
should not believe the fake news crap
and the media would not here's what
President had this at President Trump
had to say about this yesterday remember
they have the biggest best strongest
lobbyists and they're doing a number
just stick with us don't believe that
crap you see from these people to fake
news okay so everybody on the left one
nuts over this how could he say that you
shouldn't believe the stuff you read the
stuff that you see it's Orwellian he's
saying believe me not the press right as
opposed to Barack Obama who said don't
believe the propaganda over at Fox News
this is nothing new this is nothing new
and why should we believe the press when
they are constantly fibbing about things
like really there are a lot of times
when the press undercuts its own
credibility I'll give you a perfect
example so yesterday Jeff Sessions
or the day before he was speaking at
Turning Point USA which is this Bay it's
a big high school then two over in
Washington DC a lot of big names over
there my friend Calcasieu if I've
mentored a little bit he helped put
together the speaker's list well Jeff
Sessions the Attorney General spoke
there at a certain point the students
started chanting lock her up now I've
been in a position like this I was at
CPAC and people started chanting lock
her up and my immediate response was
there's no reason to lock her up because
she's already living in a hell of her
own making and she's wandering around
the woods of upstate New York
Jeff sessions however is sort of taken
aback by the locker up chance and he
starts kind of torte lling over it and
he and he sort of then moves on with his
speech here's what it sounded like
well so and then he says something like
I heard that a lot during the campaign
the media immediately started running
headlines about how Jeff Sessions had
lead chance of lock her up I'm not
kidding
Katie tore over NBC said Jeff sessions
led chance of lock her up over on MSNBC
he did not lead a chant they started
lock it they started chanting lock her
up he kind of told about it cuz it's a
little bit funny and then he moved on
with his speech but if you just read the
media headlines it sounds like the
Attorney General of the United States is
abusing his power by standing there in
chanting lock her up with a bunch of
students ok the another great example of
the media's malfeasance on these topics
so my friend Ellie Stuckey hey Ellie's
great she's over at CR TV she's a great
outlet you should check it out and Ally
is she does these sort of periodic
videos how do I know she does parodic
videos because I did one with her okay
just a few weeks ago is actually at a at
a turning point USA that she was there
to cover it and we went in a room with
her cameraman and she did a basically a
ripoff of between two ferns
she sat across from me and she asked me
absurd questions and I sort of laughed
awkwardly at the absurdity of the
questions this is an ally Schneck right
she generates an awful lot of satire
content so she took an interview we
showed you and you listened to portions
of this same interview with Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez okay we actually played
this interview on the others with
Margaret Hoover on PBS it's the same
interview in which Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez suggested that she didn't know
anything about foreign policy and she
obviously didn't know anything about
capitalism or economics and she looked
like an idiot so what Ellie did is she
cobbled together a video of her
questioning Alexandra Ocasio Cortez it
was very funny it was obviously not real
and the reason you know it's not real is
because the background for Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez is not even remotely the
same as the background in the video for
Allie Stuckey it is obvious that it's
not that's not you know that the Cortez
is not sitting down with Allie Stuckey
you can also tell because in some of the
cutaway shots you can see Margaret
Hoover's dress which is green and then
when they cut away to Allie Stuckey
she's wearing a blue dress it's
completely a different dress okay here
is what it sounded like and then I'll
tell you how the media reacted to this
because it's completely insane how do
you respond to the people who say that
socialism has never worked
capitalism with
the most efficient and best economy
perhaps abject poverty is at the lowest
level it's ever been because of
capitalism well I think the numbers that
you just talked about is part of the
problem I I don't understand oh so what
do you hope to accomplish when you're in
Congress this is a really good question
so what is it I just think that that's
the wrong question okay so why should
voters vote for you you vote it's it's
Democratic okay and and obviously it is
it is ally mocking the hell out of
Alexandra Oh Kashia cortes which is fine
you know how I know it's fine because
the left it does this exact same tactic
all the time for instance last week
Stephen Colbert I will get to Stephen
Colbert in just a second because I'm
gonna show you how the left uses this
exact same tactic and then I'll show
I'll give you the punchline exactly how
the left treated the Sally Stuckey video
because it's totally insane first I want
to remind you that you might be spending
too much on your credit cards right
we've been living on credit for a very
long time where you're buying it now
then you're paying for it later except
you're now paying exorbitant fees
because you didn't pay off your credit
card on time well with Lending Club you
can consolidate your debt or pay off
your credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club has
helped millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to
the bank no high interest credit cards
just go to Lending Club com tell them
about yourself how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you and if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
accounts in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform over
thirty five billion dollars in loans
issued it really is very simple go check
them out Lending Club com /ban you can
check your rate in minutes you can
borrow up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club calm slash Spencer
you're doing construction on your house
in two quick loan or you want to
consolidate those credit card bills
Lending Club does it for you Lending
Club com /ban all loans all loans made
by web bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender go check it out right now Lending
Club comm /ban it's an easy way to get a
loan if you qualify and you can find out
if you do right now Lending Club com
slash been used that /bin so you can
check your rate in minutes and then
borrow up to 40 grand check it out
Lending Club com /ban okay so Ellie
Stuckey cuts this video with
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez and as I say
this this parodic video in which she
sits across from the radical socialist
self-described Democratic Socialist
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez goes viral
that's like a million hits on Facebook
and there's nothing unusual about this
tactic right it's a he's a frequent
comedic tactic how do I know this
because Stephen Colbert did it last week
with President Trump so President Trump
did an interview with Bret Baier except
Stephen Colbert has significantly better
graphic artists than Ali does Ali
basically just cut back and forth one
camera shots of her face in Alexandria
Ocasio cortezes face here the producers
over at Stephen Colbert show are
actually able to essentially superimpose
Stephen Colbert over Brett bear in this
particular interview and so or with Sean
Hannity rather in this particular
interview
here's Colbert interviewing President
Trump using exactly the same tactic as
Alex tuck used with Alexandra Ocasio
Cortes mr. president right off the bat I
gotta say wow what a summit you managed
to bring both sides of the aisle
together to agree that you historically
sucked how do you think your buddy Vlad
came off I thought that President Putin
was very very strong what else can you
tell us about the man President Putin is
very much into undermining our
democratic process having the u.s. over
a barrel
don't tell me I'll get this playing you
like a fiddle wait what am i doing why
don't I just go to the source okay then
he actually just trots over and he sits
down with with Vladimir Putin right so
this is a frequent tactic that he's used
by folks on the left I'm old enough to
remember when you had Conan O'Brien
doing a routine where somebody would
play Bill Clinton's lips right where
they would actually be like a still
photo and then just Bill Clinton's mouth
would move and it would be as though he
was interviewing Bill Clinton all of
this is normal comedy the sort of stuff
happens all the time but how does the
left respond to basic satire which by
the way is much funnier than what
Stephen Colbert did there that is
utterly unfunny how did they respond
well Alexandre Ocasio Cortez she tweets
this she tweets Republicans are so
scared of me that they're faking videos
and presenting them as real on Facebook
because they can't deal with reality
anymore
here's one bonafide truth election day
is November 6th no one is faking the
video
I mean honestly perhaps we ought to look
into a governmental program of forced
readers redistribution of senses of
humor so she ends up with
one because this is crazy okay it is
obviously a satire video again Avila
makes satire all the time but what the
left really can't deal with okay the
real trick they can't deal with is that
some people on the right actually have a
sense of humor the left wants to paint
the right is completely humorless this
is one of their favorite things to do
what the right really is we're all John
Lithgow in Footloose we sit around
telling the kids not to dance that's our
thing but if we're ever funny at all and
it turns out that it's because we're
racist sexist bigoted homophobic or
because we're faking it so you could
forgive Alexandria Ocasio Cortez for
having no sense of humor about herself
you know as somebody who is who is
parodied on a pretty frequent basis I
can tell you I find most of the parodies
about me pretty funny but apparently if
you're you're a hardcore Democratic
Socialist humor was outlawed by Stalin a
century ago and so we ought to simply
pretend that it doesn't exist the part
of it that's hilarious though is the way
the media treat this stuff here's a how
did the media treat this so a video
producer at box tweets this out
he eats out wow this is Ocasio Cortez
PBS interview with Margaret Hoover
spliced together with the CR TV
interviewer notice they never appear on
camera together and the interviewer shot
is lit different plus higher resolution
took 1 minute on Google to sort out
reprehensible did it ever occur to this
guy that they weren't trying to make it
look like an actual interview that the
whole thing is parodic like yes it's
shot with different resolution because
it was done on the cheap because it's
not like she's spending Ali spending
tons of money on a Stephen Colbert style
implant you in the video talking to
President Trump I love that the people
on the Left were so exercised over this
I mean they were really exercised over
this the Washington Post ran a full
piece about this I am not kidding it's a
full piece from the Washington Post
about the evils of this and they tweeted
this out after a fake interview of
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes went viral its
maker said it was satire it's maker set
it with satire it's obviously satire
it's clearly satire I understand we live
in an era where people are not allowed
to make jokes or have a sense of humor
but you have to be out of your mind you
have to be so unbelievably stupid to
think that this was meant as an actual
legit interview that it amounts to
dishonesty you I Rosenberg writes the
piece he says the video travelled
quickly after being shared Monday on
Facebook gathering more than 1.5 million
views in less than a day in it Alexandre
Ocasio
Tezz the congressional candidate from
New York whose Democratic Socialist
campaign has struck a lightning bolt
into the world of democratic politics
appeared to give bizarre answers in a
two-and-a-half minute video that was
staged as an interview with conservative
commentator Allie Stuckey on the site
see our TV Ocasio Cortez shook her head
no when Stuckey asked if she had any
knowledge about how the political system
worked and seemed to imply that
Venezuela was in the middle east and was
a model of socialism but the video did
not depict a real interview despite its
caption Ally Grylls okay and the Grylls
is in scare quotes it's in the scare
quotes it's obviously satire
congressional hopeful and progressive it
girl Alexandria Ocasio Cortes instead it
used heavily edited footage after an
outcry the Facebook page for Stuckey's
show was updated to note that the video
was satire included a reference to the
original PBS show but the fact the video
traveled so widely has served as another
example of how misleading information
continues to thrive in the fast-paced
flow of information online
despite Facebook's promise to better
weed it out so now the Washington Post
is calling for regulation of Facebook
because people cannot recognize a satire
video and then you wonder why when
President Trump says why are you
listening to the media so many people on
the right not along go yeah that's right
you know when I saw this video this this
this Allie Stuckey video for the first
time says a couple of nights ago when it
first went up and my father was online
he said look at this hilarious video
everyone realized that it was funny
everyone realized it was satire except
the writers at the Washington Post and
then this writer says misinformation is
not completely outlawed according to the
company's Community Guidelines and
neither of course is satire but the
video appeared to fall into a confusing
gap between the two before it was
labeled know it says too many skeptical
eyes the video was obviously fishy and
staged but it appeared to be taken
seriously after it was shared on some
conservative-leaning pages on Facebook
this is reminiscent of when I believe is
the Washington Post who ran a fact check
on a Babylon be peace on facebook the
Babylon be is like the onion of the
right a it's just it's just incredible
it's just incredibly used tactic on the
left the fake interview it's a very
funny bit right for example I'm old
enough to remember when late-night
comedians did Bush vs. Bush did anybody
actually Jon Stewart did this did he
actually think that george w bush was
debating george w bush but did anyone
think this was anything but satire hey
here it is from you know ten years ago
mr. president let me just get specific
why are we in iraq
we will be changing the regime of Iraq
for the good of the Iraqi people
governor then I'd like to hear your
response on that if we're an arrogant
nation they'll they'll resent us I think
one way for us to end up being viewed as
the Ugly American is for us to go around
the world saying we do it this way so
should you okay so okay this is a tactic
that's frequently used and this is the
part that drives me up a wall when you
undercut your own credibility on a
regular basis members of the media it's
gonna be very difficult for you to fight
president Trump when he says that you've
destroyed your own credibility okay
before we go any further let's talk
about your impending death so let's be
real about this you're gonna plot and
when you do if you don't have life
insurance your family is going to be a
lot poorer than they were well you're
alive and earning son so go check it out
right now
71% of people say they need life
insurance only 59% of people have
coverage that means at least 12% of
people are procrastinating go check it
out policy genius the easy way to
compare life insurance online you can
compare quotes in just five minutes when
it's that easy putting it off becomes a
lot harder you can compare quotes while
you're sitting on the couch watching TV
you can compare quotes while listening
to this podcast go try it policy genius
has helped over 4 million people shop
for insurance they've placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy they
also compare disability insurance
renter's insurance health insurance if
you care about it they can cover it so
if you need life insurance but you've
been putting it off because it's too
confusing or you don't have the time
checkout policy genius it's the easy way
to compare top insurers and find the
best value for you there's no sales
pressure zero hassle and it's free
policy genius.com
when it's this easy to compare life
insurance there's no reason to put it
off fact is everybody needs life
insurance yes you go check it out policy
genius.com alrighty so the media
obviously stepping in it on a routine
basis and it's and it's it would be
hilarious if it weren't quite so sad now
in a second I want to talk about some
other agenda items on the left that
involve things including plastic straws
I'm not kidding but first you're gonna
have to go over to Daily wire calm and
subscribe so for $9.99 a month you can
get a subscription to daily we're calm
when you do you get the rest of this
show live there are some Andrew Clavin
show live the rest of Michael Mosley's
show live yeah there's there's a lot of
good stuff that you get when you become
a subscriber for a $99 annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels leftist
here's hot or cold tumblr go check it
out right
now also when you subscribe at YouTube
and you hit that little bells that
you're updated you will be able to know
when we release a new episode of our
Sunday special and this Sunday's special
is pretty awesome coming up this Sunday
micro is stopping by you know dirty jobs
micro so go check it out
okay here's what here's micro talking
about how awesome it was did you know
Ben Shapiro has a Sunday special did you
know it was on Sundays well it is did
you know that I'm his guest this Sunday
well I am did you know that watching it
will make you exponentially smarter and
more liked it will see you Sunday so
check that out the Sunday special coming
up and when you subscribe at youtube or
itunes then you can ensure that it will
arrive in your inbox just as promised go
check it out we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so when the left and the media aren't
pretending that satire videos are real
for the sake of attacking people people
on the left are also proposing some
brand new ideas there's only one problem
these brand new ideas they're basically
the same as the the old ideas so for
example elizabeth warren she's
presenting a brand new idea it's brand
new
what is her idea she wants to run for
president in 2020 and as a Native
American and she says that she wants a
50 percent tax rate that's what she's
looking for a 50 percent tax right now
let it be said that people in the top
brackets in the United States are
already paying the overwhelming majority
of actual net tax dollars toward the
federal government it's not even it's
not even close and people at the upper
end of the tax spectrum between state
and federal taxes are paying well in
excess of 40 percent if you're in the
state of California you're already
paying closer to 50 percent of your
money to taxes but Elizabeth Warren says
we need a 50 percent top tax rate that's
gonna fix all of our problems it's 50
percent obviously 200 look there was a
time in a very prosperous America an
America that was growing the middle
class in America in which working
families were doing better generation
after generation after generation where
the top marginal rate was well above 50%
ninety percent that's exactly right
hey the left never ever ever will
actually give you a straight answer on
this particular question when you say
them what is your preferred top tax rate
they'll never tell you that it's a
hundred percent but it basically is a
hundred percent now folks on the Left
will say you know when when the tax
rates were really good is when the top
marginal tax rate was ninety one percent
under JFK ignoring of course the fact
that everybody basically avoided paying
the ninety one percent top tax rate with
a variety of loopholes and deductions
but if you really believe that this is a
winning campaign in the United States a
winning campaign is I want to raise
everybody's taxes dramatically talk to
Walter Mondale circa 1984 hey this is it
this is your program let's raise taxes
incredibly high yeah genius genius ideas
from the left also outrages on the
program as well so cory booker also
wants to run for president in 2020 this
is why when people say the donald trump
is running at a disadvantage in 2020 I
just wonder who they think he's going to
run against if it's gonna be Elizabeth
who's sending smoke signals or Cory
Booker wild-eyed Cory Booker the
advantage has to be with Trump Cory
Booker is the senator from New Jersey
one of the senators from New Jersey
along with the the execrable Bob
Menendez and Cory Booker has decided
that he is going to play krazee-eyez mr.
Potatohead in his 2020 campaign he's
gonna get out his angry eyes slap those
things on and then he's going to go out
and campaign everything that he says is
five times too crazy for actual for
actual moderate politics here he is
yesterday suggesting that anyone who
supports the nomination of Brett
Kavanaugh for the Supreme Court is
complicit in evil and behind him is
Elizabeth Warren even she looks awkward
over this outrage routine and every time
cory booker speaks he thinks that he is
doing the mccarthy era have you no
decency sir and it grates really really
quickly moral outrage does not work
against president trumpet it doesn't
work on the american people when you're
talking about the nomination of Brett
Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court the left
is already attempting to mobilize
against Cavanaugh's nomination not by
suggesting that there are holes in his
legal resume or by asking specific
questions about his record or how he
will rule on future cases but simply by
stating over and over and over again
that you are evil if you support Brett
Kavanaugh well this was exactly the
thing that led to Trump's presidency in
the first place everybody on the right
got tired of hearing they will they were
evil for disagreeing politically and so
the left is doubling down on all of that
so what have we learned from the left in
the last 24 hours we've learned that
their program involves diss dishonestly
suggesting and that satire is actually
real for the purposes of attacking
people we've learned from the left that
they want tax rates radically elevated
and we've learned from the left that you
are evil if you support a judge who
disagrees with Cory Booker on abortion
this is what we've learned from the left
the radicalization of the Democratic
Party is happening in real time and this
is not me suggesting this from some
subjects objective point of view Real
Clear Politics has these charts that
shows sort of the movement in the party
politics over the past 20 years and what
you see is that the Republican Party
moved to the right leading all the way
up til 2010 and since 2010 the
Republican Party has basically been
stagnant and it's policies and what you
see is that the left Democratic Party
has moved radically to the left since
2010 and that's not a giant surprise
because just watching in real time you
can see it happening I'm old enough to
remember when Barack Obama was running
on behalf of traditional marriage and
suggesting that he didn't want to raise
taxes in 2008 and now we've got
Elizabeth Warren who's gonna run on
transgender bathrooms and 50% tax rights
that might be a little bit too radical
for the American people
now the other angle that folks on the
Left could take is that the Republicans
in Congress aren't checking president
Trump quite enough that the Republicans
in Congress are letting President Trump
have his way the problem is it's hard to
come up with the evidence that on policy
they're actually letting Trump have his
way except perhaps on the issue of
tariffs where Congress really shouldn't
seize back its power it's a it's a
legislative power under article 1 of the
Constitution to handle tariff policy but
on other areas for example on Putin the
left has suggested that the Republicans
are complicit in allowing President
Trump to sell out the country to
Vladimir Putin except for the fact that
the policy that has been promulgated by
Congress is much harsher under President
Trump than it ever was under President
Obama yesterday for example senator
Mitch McConnell the Senate Majority
Leader cocaine Mitch he came out and he
said that Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
the two of them would not be welcoming
Putin to give some sort of joint address
to the houses of Congress so they're not
gonna go along with the sort of warm
feeling the president Trump has for
Putin again the policy that Trump has
pursued via Putin is very different from
the verbiage he has spoken via Putin
with regard to Putin here is Mitch
McConnell elucidating well I can only
speak for the Congress the speaker and
I've made it clear that will not be
welcomed up here at the Capitol okay
well again if the idea is you needed to
elect Democrats to check the President
of the United States I'm failing to see
where Trump has really overridden his
constitutional boundaries except in the
area of tariffs and there is a case we
made the Republicans should stop him on
that stuff for the sake of Trump's own
presidency but the case for a Democratic
Congress has never been weaker I think
and that's why I'm so bewildered by
folks like George Will who have
suggested we need Democrats in Congress
to check president Trump you men out
like president Trump but the policy that
is emerging from the Trump
administration is not the same as
president Trump's personally his
personality and what he and what he
believes personally they're not quite
the same thing at all I'm not sure how
you trust Democrats especially
considering this final plank of the demo
pratik platform that I'm going to talk
about in just one second so final plank
of the Democratic platform apparently
for 2020 is going to be plastic straws
suck and no I don't mean that in in
punny fashion I mean that they're no
longer going to allow you to slurp
through plastic straws in cities like
San Francisco according to the San
Francisco Chronicle soon to be hurt in
San Francisco the last slurp through a
plastic straw this morning my kids
wanted to drink some tea and they wanted
to use plastic straw so I guess I am now
complicit in evil according to Cory
Booker this Board of Supervisors passed
an ordinance on Tuesday that will
prohibit the city's restaurants bars and
retailers from providing customers with
plastic items such as straws stirs or
toothpicks beginning July 1st 2019 if
the ordinance passes the board on the
second reading next week it will then be
presented to Mayor London breed if the
mayor signs the measures retailers will
be prohibited from selling single-use
food service products made with
fluorinated chemicals so you're not
going to be allowed to get like a
Starbucks cup anymore instead you're
gonna have to use biodegradable straws
that taste like corn every time you use
them bars restaurants and cafes would
only be allowed to provide products like
condiment packets and napkins upon
request or itself service stations
supervisor Asha Safi
she says this is about changing people's
behavior do you really need to offer a
straw with a glass of water well yeah I
mean I kind of want to straw so a little
bit and if by the way all of the all of
the propaganda surrounding plastic
straws is absolutely silly when people
say the plastic straws are actually
contributing to the degradation of the
environment in a serious way it's just
not true ok there's basically a survey
that was done by an eighth grader
suggesting that there are 8 million
plastic straws that are thrown into the
ocean but that's just not it's not true
it's not true ok they it's this is your
program now is to make life more so poop
on the streets in San Francisco fine
straws on the streets in San Francisco
not ok open needles on the streets of
San Francisco fine straws on the streets
of San Francisco not ok plastic straws
are not the problem if you want to talk
about ocean pollution by the way what is
really polluting oceans are nets ok
that's really what's happening the anti
strong movement is recording bloomberg
took off in 2015 after video of its
eternal what the straw stuck in its nose
went viral campaign soon followed with
activists often citing studies of the
growing ocean plastics problem but this
well-intentioned campaign assumes that
single-use plastics have much to do
ocean pollution that assumption is based
on some highly dubious data activists
and news media often claim that
Americans use 500 million plastic straws
per day which sounds awful
cuz that's stupid they're only 300
million Americans okay in this room guys
on average how many plastic straws do
you use a day a day okay that's right
okay I use zero send you uses zero
Malthus uses zero okay the the notion
that means that for all three of us
using zero in order for us to get to 500
million there has to be some person out
there who's using 10 plus 10 plastic
straws in a day but to average out to
500 million if somebody has to be using
10 plastic straws I don't know if
they're doing enough there like snortin
cocaine with straws piled up the wazoo
but that's real weird if the source of
the figure was actually a survey
conducted by a 9 year old to Australian
scientists estimated there were 8 point
3 billion plastic straws scattered on
global coastlines
but even if those straws were suddenly
washed into the sea they'd account for
point 0 3 percent of the 8 million
metric tonnes of plastics estimated 10 -
the oceans in a given year but don't
worry the city of santa barbara has also
passed into ordinance that will allow
restaurants employees to be punished
with up to 6 months of jail time or
$1000 fine
for giving plastic straws to their
customers the bill was passed
unanimously last Tuesday $1000 fine so
if you go to a table and you just give
four plastic straws to people that's
$4,000 or you could do two and a half
years in jail you can do two years in
jail for giving for customers plastic
straws Santa Barbara's ordinance is
likely the most severe straw ban in the
country but of course it is not the only
one by the way Santa Barbara didn't just
ban plastics for us they also ban
compostable straws so I guess there are
no straws available at all so I guess
you're a disabled person who actually
needs to sip through a straw you're
basically screwed right I mean I guess
that you could probably have a lawsuit
based on this this is this is pretty
nuts okay this is pretty nut stuff but
again the left is not known for its
moderation on issues of virtue signaling
and this is merely the latest example of
all of that so yeah I'm very glad that
the leftist have decided the crucial
threats to the planet is plastic straws
and that that must be ended immediately
but the spread of poop on sidewalks
that's cool homeless people occupying
every square inch of Los Angeles that's
fine just make sure those homeless
people don't have plastic straws while
they're spreading disease at Skid Row
in Los Angeles a thing that is actually
happening and priorities guys priorities
okay time for them seeing things I like
then some things I hate and then we'll
do a Somme and uplifting song I like
Wednesdays cuz we do Psalms okay so we
were going to do a thing I like the
thing I like today we're doing jazz all
this week Sarah Vaughn one of the great
voices of all time this is from her live
in Japan album and it is just
spectacular she is again a a
once-in-a-century voice he's Sarah
Vaughn singing for you
[Music]
you know jazz really is the great
American musical form and it's obviously
presents in stuff like this you know
from from the Blues that we played
yesterday to the the kind of the kind of
torch songs that you hear her from Sarah
Vaughn it's present in George Gershwin
jazz is a truly great all-american form
of music largely begun by black folks in
the United States and that's why when I
rip on rap because this is actually
music okay again I don't have to do my
spiel about how much I hate rap suffice
it to say I don't like rap okay time for
a couple of things that I hate so the
thing that I hate today this is really
tragic so Demi Lovato suffered a drug
overdose she's apparently awake and
responsive at this point she had a drug
overdose people were saying that she had
a heroin overdose she was found
unconscious when they arrived her home
according to media reports she was
treated with narcan which is an
emergency treatment for narcotic
overdoses at her home I'm not sure what
the story is on how she actually became
an addict so I think the story is that
she's told that she became addicted to
the cocaine oh and she was actually on
Disney Channel and then I guess she
transferred over into heroin so this
wasn't the typical sort of story that
you hear with regard to heroin addiction
in in sort of more prosperous
communities where somebody goes to the
doctor and then they are prescribed some
sort of opioid and they can't get the
the high from the opioid that they used
to and the prescription runs out so they
start using heroin black tar heroin
instead there's a great book by it
called dreamland by a guy named Sam
Quinn ona's that I've recommended on the
show before about the problem of heroin
trafficking in the United States but
there is something to be said about the
idea that when you have a severe
epidemic of drugs in in upper-class
communities I mean economically viable
communities that it's it's it's not
something you can blame on economics
it's it's something that you do have to
blame at a certain point on lack of a a
moral framework for folks and that's not
to suggest that demi lovato is not a
victim of her own of her own addiction I
think that addiction can be treated as a
disease I think we have to treat it as a
disease it is also something that self
control helps with which is why you have
12-step programs as I've talked about a
little bit earlier this week you know as
it but the idea that society as a whole
is responsible for addictions like Demi
Lovato I have a bit of a problem with
this the reason that I say this is
because the same day that's happened
with Demi Lovato there's an article in a
publication called
nme by a guy named Barry Nicholson and
it says the most modern tragedy why
we're all to blame for the death of Amy
Winehouse and I just thought to myself
well I'm not I have an alibi
okay Amy Winehouse's death has nothing
to do with me
and the the article essentially suggests
that we are all complicit why are we
complicit in her death at the film's
core is a single deeply unsettling
question how did a happy healthy
outrageously gifted 14 year old glimpsed
in its opening moments become a
traumatized figure we all recognize from
her final months there are no easy
answers by the end the coroner's verdict
of death by misadventure doesn't seem to
tell the whole story this was death by a
thousand cuts and agonizingly drawn out
to Mai's of cumulative influences
appetites and mistakes some so the basic
suggestion is that by humoring our most
talented people in their excesses that
we are complicit in their fall I think
there is some truth to that to the
people who immediately surround a star I
think there are a lot of people who when
you get famous there are a lot of folks
who surround you who are going to tell
you yes to a lot of things and people
who want to be your friends we're going
to tell you yes to anything that you
want to hear because saying no means
you're gonna be unpopular with the
famous cool kid you know we here at the
offices know a lot of very famous people
and this is a serious problem with
famous people is that they're they're
often told yes by their hangers-on and
being told yes a lot means that you're
going to start engaging in more and more
outrageous excesses now that's why it's
important to surround yourself with good
people as a famous person in the end
regardless of whether you are famous or
whether you are not if you believe in
the idea that there is some level of
personal responsibility for your own
activity I think blaming society for
consuming your product is a little bit
over the top I don't think that it's
it's the people who watched Roseanne who
are responsible for Roseanne having
serious life problems I don't think that
it's the people who bought Amy Winehouse
albums are responsible for Amy Winehouse
doing what she did I don't think it's
the people who were fans of Demi Lovato
who are responsible for Demi Lovato
doing what she did either I'm not
suggesting by the way the Demi Lovato
suggests that it is their fault but I
think there's a tendency on the part of
the media to suggest that personal
problems are actually societal problems
and societal problems are actually
personal problems and that is a serious
problem yeah I think the only way we're
going to recover from this is with the
the belief that a more virtuous society
in which we are Ella we are all held to
account and in which we protect each
other from our excesses by not setting
stumbling blocks in front of the blind
that's the kind of society that's going
to protect people
who'd you have a tendency toward
addiction who's who have a tendency
toward making mistakes in their personal
life honestly prayers for for demi
lovato and i hope and pray as I would
for anyone I hope that she gets over the
issues that obviously plague her she was
sober I guess for some six years before
she sort of fell off the wagon and
that's quite terrible I hope that she
gets back on the wagon the wagon thank
God for narcan thank God that she has
the ability to to hopefully recover and
and lead a fulfilled life okay let's
let's check out a song so every
Wednesday we do as someone we're making
our way through the book today's Psalm
is Psalm 4 and what's what's really
fascinating about the Book of Psalms is
there's a really good book that I've
recommended on the show before called
poetic diction and the basic suggestion
of that book is that when you read old
poetry read ancient poetry that it feels
more substantive it feels like there is
something more whole about that poetry
than there is about modern poetry and
the reason for that is that the language
of the time if you particularly few read
Psalms in Hebrew for example it conveys
more meaning than the language now like
we in the West in English we have words
for spirit and for and for win right
these are two separate words the ruler
of the word in Hebrew is Ruach and it
encompasses both senses of the word so
the language is Richard because it has
more embedded meanings in it and I think
that you see that when you read the
Psalms so some forces for the director
of music with stringed instruments a
song of David answer me when I call to
you my righteous God give me a relief
from my distress have mercy on me and
hear my prayer how long will you people
turn my glory into shame this is God
saying to David how long will you love
delusions and seek false gods know that
the Lord has set apart his faithful
servant for himself the Lord hears when
I call to him tremble and do not sin
when you are on your beds search your
hearts and be silent offer the
sacrifices of the righteous and trust in
the Lord you know the idea of silence in
the face of cosmic injustice is
something that Judaism kind of goes back
and forth on judeo-christianity goes
back and forth on if you read the the
Old Testament there's a lot of
protesting against perceived and
justices on part of God so for example
the book of Job is all about this where
job experiences awful awful cosmic
injustice and God's final answer is to
be silent what is it about silence that
matters here I don't think that it's
just God saying you ought to be silent
because I know best for you I think it's
about the idea that when you sit in
silence it causes you to think until
now sila when you're talking you're not
listening and talking to God is useful
praying to God is useful but listening
and trying to figure out what it is that
might make your life better on your own
might be a better solution than
constantly crying out to the heavens
silence is is a very effective tool it's
it's one of the reasons why I think
Eastern forms of meditation in many
cases are extraordinarily useful the
idea of actually just taking a break and
shutting up for a second in politics if
we did this a little more if we shut up
a little bit more and listen to a little
more and talked a little bit less I
think that we'd all be better off I
think it's certainly true when it comes
to our personal interactions with the
divine as well and I'm not saying that
God is going to speak to you because I
don't think that most people have the
ability of prophecy but I do think that
you just listening is going to allow you
to maybe see beyond yourself this is
true for all of us it's the hardest
thing to do is to be silent in the face
of perceived injustice from the cosmic
but perhaps we can get beyond ourselves
if we're if we're not talking quite so
much okay well we'll be back here
tomorrow with all the ladies and we'll
talk about it well then I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens edited by Alex and Garo Audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing